grandpa you know do I look like a diva
yes yeah am I gonna act like a diva yes
what do I start with know where to start
really like a little foundation a little
concealer this is like a spirit was
hiding in here and now I just released
it yeah it's supposed to get on your
face happen it a little bit off because
oh that is so funny mom no this powders
loose yeah they went straight for my
crotch we got some bags under your eyes
do you have any concealer in there
mm-hmm we do a concealer wow this is
amazing
there we go I might actually start using
this so yeah for under-eye bag and also
like this I don't have any of those cuz
I'm flawless ah you're perfect
this is my favorite thing this is like
whoa this is like the Photoshop tool you
do wanted to have kind of like a blended
look though so it's not just a
hodgepodge
okay I'm blending I'm blending I just
looked over you're definitely using the
wrong brush for that maybe this is a new
technique I don't know about it it
actually goes really well and we have to
Speedman oh okay the only problem right
now cuz I want to throw up let me see is
there too much sort of thing you can
definitely put too much green eyeshadow
it looks like somebody punched me in the
face right there oh shoot I did mess up
I have like this little bit right here
alright and you're blending and you're
putting blue everywhere what's wrong I'm
sorry lookit you can run to eyeliner oh
eyeliner so that's the challenge that's
the hardest thing you're going to murder
me if I lose an eyeball it is your phone
uh-huh
it's so scary yeah smooth real but that
driver whoa whoa whoa because I'm going
to do this like oh damn this makes you
look so hot I'm attracted to myself
right I wasn't supposed to go all the
way on the bottom was I
no this is good this is right but I just
hate it
so yeah just brush it on oh here I you
think so oh oh [ __ ] off holes how do you
not get it on your face you just don't
what's left lipstick so do I'd use the
pointy end or the flat end I'm moving
the car
what's happening beautiful it's not
terrible oh wow that's as far as I'll go
very nice very I would say you can maybe
just go with a little bit of a lighter
touch if you're going on everyday look
but I'd have to say like 7 7 for a guy
for a guy I guess I get the handicapped
or if you were a preteen girl
okay so we're all done Jared um overall
I would say 10 out of 10 thought I might
be biased because I love you
Oh